une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann
marcel carton les otages français au
liban n'ont toujours pas été libéré les
otages français au liban vont ils se
retrouver au coeur d'une polémique dans
la campagne électorale depuis quelques
jours nous nous posons sérieusement la
question il faut dire que de rumeurs en
rumeurs plusieurs journaux arabes ont
évoqué des coups tordus des basses
manoeuvres et des mensonges autour de la
sphère des otages hier soir nouveau
rebondissement plus concret celui là un
homme d'affaires syrien qui avait été
jusqu'en mars 86 l'un des émissaires de
l'elysée dans cette affaire a fait
l'objet d'un arrêté d'expulsion
on lui reproche notamment d'avoir gêné
par son action la politique du
gouvernement français
voilà sur les faits nous allons y
revenir dans quelques instants beaucoup
plus longuement
en attendant on a l'impression que la
sérénité de façade affiché par françois
mitterrand et jacques chirac
masques et peut-être d'autres
affrontements en coulisses philippe
gassot l'homme qui a été expulsé c'est
lui omran adam un homme d'affaires
syrien un proche du président hafez
el-assad
il est porteur d'un passeport
diplomatique délivré par damas cet homme
qui vit en france depuis 20 ans vient
d'être frappé par une mesure d'urgence
absolue émissaire officieux de l'élysée
en 1985 il a été chargé d'intervenir
dans le processus de négociations
destinées à obtenir la libération des
otages français détenus au liban dans sa
dernière intervention publique il ya
quinze jours
il indique que l'armée syrienne
s'apprêtait à investir le sanctuaire du
hezbollah dans le sud de beyrouth
une information démentie par la syrie
qui précise que monsieur adam ne parle
plus qu en son nom propre
depuis 86 déclare charles pasqua
monsieur rade dame n'a pas servi
d'intermédiaire depuis plus de trois
années que son prisonnier les otages
français au liban rumeurs informations
et contre informations ont été le lot
quasi quotidien de la presse libanaise
et de celle des pays du golfe
ce fut à nouveau le cas le 22 avril
dernier lorsqu un falcon 50 immatriculé
en suisse se pose sur l'aéroport de
beyrouth
on indiqué de sources syriennes que les
otages seront libérés dans les heures
qui viennent pour le cheikh fadlallah
c'est une affaire de quelques jours le
principal négociateur
en charles marchiani qui représente le
ministère de l'intérieur rentrer sans
les otages la presse libanaise se
déchaînent à le dire un journal de
droite publié à beyrouth est indique
qu'il ya eu une promesse de 150 millions
de francs et que le hezbollah aurait
demandé dix millions de plus la voix du
liban radio chrétienne sans citer ses
sources parlent de dissension et de
désaccords de dernière minute apparues
au sein du gouvernement français
un différend qui retard de la libération
le quotidien koweïtien al-qabas
le 29 avril dernier sort à la une sur
deux colonnes un papier qui met en cause
le président français et le diplomate
eric rouleau ce dernier dit al qabas est
intervenu pour empêcher la libération
des otages le lendemain vendredi le
journal koweïtien dément toujours à la
une dimanche al qabas revient à sa
première version
hier un autre journal pro syriens cette
fois de beyrouth indiquent peut être
inspiré par monsieur adam qu'avant mars
86 le rpr a envoyé des émissaires afin
de bloquer les négociations à propos des
otages dans cette partie du monde
les rumeurs deviennent souvent des
informations qui change selon que c'est
l'un ou l'autre qui souffle sur le feu